if you want to have any understanding of
who we are as a people as an American
people we have to know
we have to know how America and how our
great country was founded and what
documents tell us how our government
acts and what rights it hath and also
what the role of man in our country is
the Constitution is important for every
citizen to study because therein lies
founding principles and rules of our
government and citizens who don't know
the Constitution and the Bill of Rights
don't don't know their rights and will
get run over by people seeking to to
abuse to abused the system well I have
the extremely good fortune of getting to
study the Constitution as part of my job
and I'll tell you what it's been a lot
of fun getting to see people excited
about relearning those founding
documents and those first principles
I've witnessed conversations between
citizens academics and policymakers turn
from focusing on a particular bill or
piece of legislation towards the bigger
picture of what should self-government
under law look like and getting to
witness that debate literally shift
toward something higher is definitely
very encouraging and it's one of the
best parts of my job